well we begin with breaking news now
Israel has carried out air strikes on
the Gaza Strip
this amateur video appears to show one
of those missiles Landing Israel
launched the strikes after several
Rockets were fired from Gaza into Israel
just a few hours ago
let's speak to yumna outside she joins
us on the phone now from the Gaza
stripper you'll know what more can you
tell us
yes Gary so we woke up this morning on
the start of air strikes in different
areas if they cause this trip the
airstrikes were said to be responding to
six rockets that were launched in the
early hours of dawn on Thursday towards
Israeli Towns now five rockets were
intercepted by the Israeli Iron Dome
design system while one rocket fell in
an empty area according to Israeli
military uh the Israeli airstrikes came
particularly on two sides of Hamas or El
Pasad brigades the military wing of
Hamas one in a British refugee camp a
very very crowded densely populated area
around that area
uh we don't know the amounts of Damages
but this site uh Isa al-batran's site
was actually targeted a number of times
by a number of missiles another site is
the better site it was located or it is
located in the western Gaza Strip at a
short refugee camp another also very
densely populated areas no casualties
were reported at all uh while also uh
the policy of factions according to
local sources fired machine guns at uh
fire at the Israeli War plays over the
Godzilla strip
in our side in Gaza for now thank you